the federal government is extending the
nationwide eviction moratorium through
june 30th
it was supposed to expire on wednesday
the i-team's david charns joining us in
studio this afternoon with what this
means
for nevada well christian it's certainly
good news for people who can't pay the
rent because of the pandemic but
remember that all that back rent will
eventually
have to be paid the moratorium applies
to most tenants and allows people to
remain in their homes
even if they cannot pay rent right now
now remember this isn't automatic you
have to make less than a hundred
thousand dollars a year
show covet has impacted your income
prove you have nowhere else to go
and also sign a declaration and then
give that to your landlord
the executive director of the nevada
state department association says the
best thing you can do right now as a
tenant
is talk to your landlord about making
payments when you can
i think communication with your landlord
is imperative it is
crucial we want to know you know whether
or not you're going to be making a rent
payment because right now if we haven't
heard from you we're assuming that
you're not
of course rent coming up on thursday
april 1st
now nevada's state level election
moratorium which basically provides the
same protections
as the federal one that one expires
wednesday
spokesperson for governor sisilak tells
me that their office is now determining
whether or not to extend the state's
moratorium but essentially the federal
cdc moratorium
does the same thing now there is money
available from right here in clark
county to help you pay your rent
it's called the chap program that is
c-h-a-p
you can find a link to all that and
other resources right now on
eightnewsnow.com
i'm david charns eight news now